oh hi everybody i'm chris kohler and
this is game life now i'm joined once
again by wired magazine's chris baker we
have been playing a lot of grand theft
auto four like a lot of grand theft auto
four and you know we actually couldn't
be any more different I play grand theft
auto to back in college but I never
actually played any of the 3d Grand
Theft Auto games before last month
whereas I being a normal American played
grand theft auto 3 vice city and san
andreas obsessively on last generation
consoles now as I said I actually went
back and played some of the earlier
Grand Theft Auto games just to give
myself a sense of where the series has
been leading up to the release of GTA 4
dad that you just can't really
appreciate them out of their historical
moment I mean driving down the streets
of vice city rocking Herbie Hancock's
song rocket yeah that's crazy back in
the day well at least I get to
experience grand theft auto four in its
true historical moment
along the way I discovered that the
Grand Theft Auto series really they
these aren't my games they're clever
they're funny they're innovative but
they're not polished I was expecting the
same with grand theft auto four but I
was pleasantly surprised to find that
it's a real quantum leap everything is
so much more polished so much more
inviting to play it's true that the last
generation GTA games seem to kind of
Teeter on the brink of being broken they
just push the limits of what the
PlayStation 2 is capable of but the tech
is so much more robust with grand theft
auto floor everything that was bad has
been minimized it's little things like
the fact that V game auto loads when you
first turn it on the fact that it auto
saves after every mission I mean all the
little annoyances that eventually maybe
you know sick of playing the older GTA
games are not a problem here it's going
to change the way people play this game
you know the the conventional wisdom is
that Grand Theft Auto games people sort
of play the missions for a while then go
off on these random killing sprees and I
don't think people are going to do that
with this game and a big reason for that
is that they've made a really big leap
in terms of the cinematics no san
andreas is movie scenes the characters
they were good but these in GTA four are
pitch perfect i find myself so
interested in the characters like Roman
Nico's crazy cousin they're they're real
and it's not because the graphics are
good which they're not and it's not the
animation is lifelike which it isn't
it's the acting the writing the timing
it's also natural what you keep staring
at me outburst one of your eyeballs
gorgeous face guy is the creepy
if I'm a break he's snow in the country
I can see that did you walk here from
1985 yeah excellent the script is
incredible some reviewers are comparing
the characters in the dialogue to what
you find on shows like The Sopranos to
the wire whatever I mean the writers of
cop shows didn't have to write redundant
dialogue so that if you play a mission
over and over again four or five times
you're still hearing new stuff TV
writers don't have to write for
different branches of a story path
the way dan houser and Rupert Humphries
did for GTA 4 I mean writing of this
quality deserves to be judged on its own
merit not analogy to death it's true i
mean if these guys these guys could
write us us an episode of the sopranos
you know they could write an episode of
the wire but this I really think when
you start to look at all the writing
that's in GTA for the fact that it all
has to be up to this quality standard
that the volume is just so crazy that it
must be much more difficult to do this
than to do just an episode of a TV show
if I had complaints about the story it's
just that the the over-the-top satire
you you get from the world around you
from TV shows and radio and the internet
and billboards sometimes it doesn't
quite mesh with the far more realistic
and nuanced characters and story line it
did pull me out of the moment once or
twice i don't know i mean real life is
also makes it funny and serious right
like i can sit down and watch a funny
show on television but it doesn't make
my actual real-life problems any any
less serious doesn't pulled me out of
the moment and and so in that sense it
is a lot quite a bit like real life you
know the comedy in the game is the
tension breaker for the very serious
story what i'm amazed by is how far they
got with the M rating how far they
pushed it what they can get away with
like if you own the internet there is a
mail-order bride website called point
click ship a bitch calm I don't know if
you've ever laughed I've laughed at
video games before I don't think I've
ever laughed so long so loud at a video
game with all of the jokes that they
pack into this thing some of it really
is absolutely terrific they've always
done great very dark satire in these
games these games are a critique of
America they're made in scotland the the
writer and the producer are from England
and it's just some of it this time is
absolutely worthy of the onion or worthy
of Jon Stewart the fact that this game
is set in the present day was the last
to where were sort of period pieces has
really amped up the humor you know
they're back in their hometown of New
York and the present day and they're
commenting on all the stuff around them
that really annoys them you can tell
that they're really
upset about the fact that tourists
continue to pay a fortune to go see
stomped hence they've got the show
banging on trash can lids for an hour
you know it's it's just merciless satire
and it's so spot-on glad but more than
all that what impressed me the most
about grand theft auto four is just how
real the city feels again it's not a
matter of you know the the technical
quality of the graphics it's the design
that's how they capture the realistic
feeling of a city like I don't know if
anybody else gets this but when i'm in a
cab going around the city late at night
a real city i'm always struck by this
sense of melancholy a sense of isolation
even though you're surrounded by all
these people it's a really really
distinct feeling and the first night
that I was just driving around in
Liberty City I got that exact same
feeling and I was just so struck by how
they were able to recreate that emotion
yeah they have a word for it at rockstar
for all their games you know bully The
Midnight Club games they call it the
vibe you know just what what you soak up
in the world at any given moment and
their absolute masters of that their
this ability to step back and really
think about the total effect of every
element of this game world and GTA 4
it's a massive leap forward no game has
ever had a vibe like this ah these are
the moments i cherish
bye